Oh no.
DJers,
if you're watching this, if any DJers are watching this, because
I'm obsessed, and I'm doing unhinged coverage, here's your opportunity
to prove me wrong, okay? And I only say this because I know how
badly it will with Destiny. DJers, if you want to prove that
Kyla is love, people do like her for real. They really do, then
it's your job to come out and support the Bridges podcast. Support
its reclamation. Support its reformation. Okay. Destiny, please
start doing content with Noto Eerite on a weekly cadence again.
I think you really owe that to her as a friend. She stood by
you in your time of need when you were down. You should do this
content with her. Bring back Bridges. Bring back the Bridges
podcast. Okay, right now. Show your support. DJ Gers, you get
Kyla likes, views, Patreon subs. Okay, you need to support support.
It's critical or it won't come back. It's up to you guys, the
fans, the viewers. Make it happen. See you guys.
That's not it. Where is this? Here it is. Here it is. Here it
is. Here it is. >> They don't care about >> All right.
All right. All right. All right. What about Destiny debating
the Trumpers?
I don't know. I didn't watch any of that. Oh, right, right, right,
right, right, right, right. I forgot. So, this is where
So, when was this? Oh, was uploaded a day ago. I believe this
is about a week ago. And you hear Arodite go, "Hey guys, just
want to let you know I have like a debate planned with Techone."
Did I see that Hutch is gonna debate Queen? I did. Yeah. Beginning
is just tech issues. Okay. Okay. We'll check this out in just
a second. Just give me a second, guys. We'll we'll get this fig
>> issues off the bat.
>> I'm going to drop it. >> Here we go.
>> It's more than likely if you're like, "Hey, what a microphone.
Whatever. And then they can't hear, they'll tell you. >> Last
post. Oh Jesus. Last pirate thing, but even the Verge posted
as subathon hitting records. You don't know what the funny thing
is? I'm willing to bet
I'm willing to bet that he was he spent the money himself,
right? How much you want to bet that he spent the Sorry. He spent
most of the money himself and that he sent this to the Verge.
That's actually the allegation I wanted to do. That he sent the
this this to the Verge himself. He was like, "Oh, here you go.
Look, this guy's like breaking records. This is the record subathon.
Hype level literally over a hundred. Congrats to Pirate Software
and his community on setting a whole new bar with the hypest
hype train ever. Kappa Infinite emote dropping in chat for hype
train
Game developer Jason Thoral, better known by the moniker Pirate
Software, has set a new Twitch hype train world record with his
channel reaching level 106 on April 1st. Once the hype train
was initiated, it took Hull roughly 3 hours to beat his previous
level 55 world record from December with viewers contributing
54,380
gifted subs alongside regular subscriptions and
bits, likely earning Hull a healthy six figure sum in the process.
Maybe not so likely. Maybe not. Take his take his unique emotes
away. This guy cheated. We have proof of the cheating. Take the
unique unique emotes away. Okay, Kappa Infinite. No way. Get
it away from him. Starting around 12 minutes is fine. Okay. Okay,
got it. We'll check it out. Hype trains, a feature that Twitch
launched in 2020, are a limited time event triggered when a channel
receives an uptick in bits or subscriptions pushing past a streamer
to a designated threshold. While we won't know the official figure
paid by Hull's community, it's sure to be significant. In the
US, gifted subs range between $5 and $25, and 100 bits can be
purchased for $1.40.
The new record set by Hulk comes just days after Twitch introduced
new hype train rewards that can be obtained by reaching level
100, making him the first streamer to unlock the Kappa Infinite
emote. According to Hulk, the Kappa Infinite emote is rolling
out gradually to hype train participants because the event hit
the website so hard they had to rate limit the delivery. Damn.
Damn. So, industry sponsors paid big money to boost the train.
Possibly.
All right. I uh I just noticed I didn't walk away earlier when
I was going to. I'll be right back in just a second, guys. I'm
going to hit play on this. We're going to listen. I am listening.
Okay, I'm here. But I'm grabb some water and use the bathroom
real quick. I messaged some people. Should be some people dropping
in throughout the night. We'll see. I'm just going to leave the
I'm going to sit in the open channel. People want to drop in.
If you're watching the stream, you want to hop on, you let me
know. Okay. Hit play. >> Can you guys hear us pretty all
right? How about now? Can you hear us pretty all right? Can Can
you hear me or >> someone said, "Kyla, when's the Picasso
>> I don't know.
>> we have the dyslexic reading. >> How do you feel
about abstract art?
>> Picasso. Oh my god.
>> Oh, we were talking about doing it today. Probably Monday
then.
>> Probably Monday. >> Well, you have the tactone.
thing on >> I'll I'll do it after I talk to you said >> Yeah,
guys, I'm going live with Techone tomorrow. Big streamer. >> Oh,
cool. >> Yeah, we're doing
>> She's going live with Techone. You guys should follow
her. If you don't already follow Kyla, you guys got to follow
her. It's not so aerodite. >> Oh my god, we lost out on
humanizing
Guys, we couldn't humanize Teone.
Is that why she's to Destiny? It seems to be the case that when
she was saying, "Oh, well, we can't collab with Techone." And
then she said the, "Thanks, by the way." She lost her collab
with Techone. She couldn't humanize Teone.
She couldn't make Lollie cool for everybody. Okay.
So, Teone canceled. That's what she said. Yeah. Teone is an actual
mutant. Well, he's not a good person. I don't know why we're
humanizing him while he is How can you be How can you want to
humanize Teone while like the you have all these criticisms?
while you deflect criticism with guys don't criticize Zo or Z
sorry don't criticize her bookkeeping Trump's in office and then
you take Teone who's like opening openly shilling and a part
of the asthma gold sphere okay for Trump they're openly shilling
for Trump it's >> if you go to Tik Tok you can follow her
there or like Instagram >> d i t e spell it >> yeah
spell it don't let her >> e r u d i t e not so e r u d
i There you
>> X Maggot here. Okay. On this full it t >> not
so e r u d i t e.
>> There you go. >> X maga here. Okay. On full te.
>> Okay. On to full te.
>> I don't know what's going on right now. >> I'm
confused. >> I'm stuck in a loop.
>> I mean,
I know it's changed a lot. It used to mean people who really
liked it for >> Do we have another debate coming up or
another Unfuck America corpor event? Yes, we do. >> We
do. We have lots more coming up, >> I don't know how much
I'm going to watch of them just chilling here cuz I do believe
eventually they should while they're in the hot tub talk about
some people who end up in their chat, right? Yeah. They end up
like debating and stuff. So, we'll we'll skim this. We'll splong
through the VOD and see where we can get to. Okay.
>> Yeah. Follow us on We have lots more coming up, guys.
>> I thought it was just people who like
this person reading the comments. I mean >> that's ableist.
>> Why is it >> ontologically confused whenever I
watch aite? I feel the same way.
>> It says cougar beatrice cougar.
>> Okay. I know a person named preer. Am I going to ask
techone about death? So I do a show called the humanizing. Do
you want me to hold this? I feel so bad.
>> Um I do a show called the humanizing. >> Oh. Oh
no. Moments before disaster. She's going to explain how and how
and why she's doing a show with techone. cuz I I'm trying to
humanize controversial figures to like help us see content creators
and media figures as like 3D people. Um I don't litigate their
drama because I don't want to I'm good on litigating drama. Uh
what I want to do is understand like why and how people are the
way that they are. So whatever Tech's principles and values are,
I want to know why he holds them. I don't really want to get
into like do you think Steven's mean? It's like yeah, Steven's
being mean. Like obviously um that's obvious. I don't really
want to like litigate all the details of it. Uh, in the same
way that like Techone had a bunch of drama with like previous
OTK content creators. Not going to litigate that either. Um,
but I will try to understand like why he thinks what he does
about the situation if he brings it >> They said that's
fair and very noble. >> Um, but I will try to understand
like why he thinks what he does about the situation if he brings
it up. >> They said that's fair and very noble. >> Understand
like why he thinks >> what
do you like? This is the YouTube VOD by the way. The YouTube
VOD's doing >> Yeah, those funnel parts were great. >> You
have to do I stole some. They were the only one who didn't get
any. >> Oh, stole some. I thought you said you saw someone.
I was like
>> I just I literally like >> That's good. That's
good. >> I definitely missed it. >> There you go.
>> You guys, >> I'm not I swear to God I'm not rewinding
the video. It's going normally. That's not me rewinding. No,
it's not me rewinding. That is not me. >> Ask any questions
you like and we'll answer them. Particular if you
>> I just jumped forward, but I've not been >> All right,
let's get some drinks now. >> Yes. Wait, does Tik Tok care
about >> As long as it's in the shot cup, they won't care.
>> Oh, if you see a bottle unl
>> cuz I be doing it in like a wooden cup all the time.
Like a literal wooden cup.
>> Any crazy leftist show up? No. No, they leave us alone.
They know better.
>> I think they know better. I hope they know better. >> Who
knows better? >> The crazy leftist to show up at a Destiny
event. >> Oh, yeah.
>> I think they know better. >> No, absolutely not.
But they didn't they didn't protest us. They said that they would
and they never >> Yeah, they said they would, but they
didn't have the G to
>> They were supposed to.
>> Everybody is so scared of us, guys. They'd never come
and counterprotest us. They'd never do it. >> Supposed
to show up and >> Oh, yeah. They There was a There was
like Tashika literally dedicated her life to making sure the
America Corps would not continue.
>> Why? Yeah, I know. >> It's crazy. >> They
can't complain about something they have nothing to make content
about. >> Yeah, that's true. Because all all far lefties
content is if you go to their Tik Tok page is them reaming other
people on the left. It's them taking down their other team members.
>> You want to know >> who is who is this speaking?
This is Mercedes. She's a Tik Tok creator, political influencer,
former manga person. Um I don't know the pronouns unfortunately.
I do know that they're this is their husband apparently
uses he him pronouns. Although somebody needs to update Mercedes
on that cuz Mercedes does confuse that multiple times throughout
this night. political powerly blue states. That's the only political
relevant to their enemy is the >> communist party pretty
much. Yeah, exactly. They don't care about the red and and I
don't think they get enough clicks and views.
>> I mean, yeah, half of an unlabelled container. That's
>> You guys can ask any questions you like.
>> Whatever you like, dude.
>> In there with you. >> That was me. That one was
me. Speed through until we get to something. >> No, they
they color the token all day long. anytime that anytime that
she shows up in a live the chat will spam.
>> It is it's not racist though. It's like deeply humanizing
just any individual essentially you must be >> it's not
just racist when they use these slurs against you. >> It's
like deeply dehumanizing and I know what that's like cuz people
call me a pick me sometimes. Sometimes that's the same as when
they use anti-black slurs against you, right?
>> People call me a pickme.
>> You're a betrayer of it. Literally that's that's >> every
commenter is white. Someone literally someone said someone said
so glad all the baddies aren't left us.
>> Thank you. >> Cheers guys. >> Wait, do we
have chaser?
>> Am I just a little? Probably.
>> Why she got her Navy Seal gear on in the hot tub? >> I
actually don't know.
It helps. >> But if it's a shot of water,
>> this is not. >> This is water. >> Are you
trying to trick me? I feel like I made gas lit. >> Silver
water. Silver water >> for TikTok. It's water, but it's
not >> This is not water. >> You can't make the faces.
>> This is water. Anything for you? >> Yeah, we're
hydrating right now. >> Wait, but we do we need to chase.
Can I like bargle the pool water?
>> Oh, yeah. There you go. >> I'm a little Guys,
I'm sorry. >> Do it off cam. No, it's >> This is
a couple of ketchup. Okay.
On the >> I was in the army for 11 years and hearing somebody
say, "Should I just gargle the tub water?" Might be the most
[__] I've ever >> Second point actually pro.
Now we know why they sounded drunk later on. >> I'm a fisherman.
Okay. >> I gargle I gargle pull water outside of like out
of a cart's mouth. Okay. >> No, you are. >> I would.
Okay. Ready? Cheers.
>> Here, I'll let you go first.
>> All right, I'm going to start timing out weirdos in
the chat. Just say no. You're going to make weird disgusting
comments. You're going to be gone. Good luck, >> Kyla.
What's the under the over under on bridge podcast being revived?
>> you know what? It's up to you guys supporting the stream.
Okay, you guys coming forth? The issue is you guys coming to
support a long time though. So, we'll see. All right, we'll see.
>> Oh, no.
DJers,
if you're watching this, if any DJers are watching this, because
I'm obsessed and I'm doing unhinged coverage, here's your opportunity
to prove me wrong. Okay? And I only say this because I know how
badly it will with Destiny. DJers, if you want to prove that
Kyla is loved, people do like her for real. They really do. Then
it's your job to come out and support the Bridges podcast. Support
its reclamation. Support its reformation. Okay, Destiny, please
start doing content with Noto Aerodite on a weekly cadence again.
I think you really owe that to her as a friend. She stood by
you in your time of need when you were down. You should do this
content with her. Bring back Bridges. Bring back the Bridges
podcast, okay? Right now. Show your support. DJers. You get Kyla
likes, views, Patreon subs. Okay? You need to support support.
It's critical or it won't come back. It's up to you guys, the
fans, the viewers. Make it happen. So, we'll see, guys. >> We'll
see. >> I'm guessing you don't drink much. Actually, I
used to, but then I like stopped. But I still like chaser. Someone
said, "So, there's a chance. It's our destiny. Like I was saying,
yeah, there's a chance. >> I'm not supposed to witness
anyway. >> She said she's not supposed to. And anyways,
please get Adam Kong to the next floor. >> Stephven is
not about building bridges with Republicans are right now. But
that's a little bit hard to brand. >> No, that's okay cuz
we're like we're just our brand isn't necessarily building bridges
with Republicans. Like that's my strong suit.
>> Bridges is literally about building >> It's really
hard to do bridges when somebody's like nuke them all. >> Hey,
so you're like just inherently, right? I am. >> Wait, did
they do bridges with a lot of people who didn't agree with them?
I thought the whole thing with bridges was it was just like people
who did agree with them or people who were neutral.
I don't think they did bridges with like Republicans and tried
to build bridges to other people. That was actually probably
the main criticism of the channel is that they just didn't do
that at all. They didn't even attempt it.
>> Also for it and then I get cancelled for building bridges.
>> Yeah, building bridges. It's a smart
>> It started out like that but then they changed it. Wait,
where did it start out like that?
with Ryan McBth with JJ McCulla. Maybe maybe is JJ like the closest
you can get the Canadian conservative.
>> Oh, really? >> You guys can ask any questions
you like.
>> Thank you. >> Soups. Try going to college. Yeah,
we want soups with us. Soup is based.
>> Oh, should try going to college? We're going to colleges.
>> Little loud for the bubbles, >> right? Yeah. >> Yeah.
The bubbles are too loud.
>> Speeding up till we get to the next question. Mercedes,
Pila, Dom, Nick,
character is cool. >> Why you misunder
>> They changed the goal because of the firefighter tweets,
I think. Oh,
>> what's up, man? >> What up, brother?
>> No. Who's A Smith? >> Isn't he the
Hey guys? So, earlier we were giving all of our most Republican
hot takes. Do you guys want to see our most conservative hot
takes?
>> Oh, super. That's Iran. Yes. Gotcha. >> Did you
see that beeping with Charlie? >> I did, but I'm not prized
like
I >> J. Can you all take your countryman Kyla
>> Uh, Kyla is far less harmful in Canada. Okay. But she's
far more funny to me in the United States. She's like she she
doesn't have a voice in Canada. There's nothing going on in Canada
for her. She's far more funny in the United States where she
just causes chaos and gets to be, you know. I No, I won't. I
won't. It's important that she continue to do this and make content
for me. melt down and in the left I hope I hope liberals are
like like oh the >> I hope okay I hope liberals are like
huh ma's melting down over the epste in Iraq >> should
we a shame them for voting for Trump and never allow them back
or b welcome them back and rip them a little bit for their dumb
ass choices >> no no hold on I think I think I'll prefer
D cancelce liberal content creator take away from the >> Mr.
woman. Thank you for the 12 months. Let's go. Thank you. Thank
you. >> I think there's a growing version group of people
who have realized that like the issue with that like the left
side that are psycho are like the mentally ill people trapped
>> hold on >> home that like need to get off the
internet and genuinely just like get pug into their community
because that that would be best for them but instead they're
like venting their distress online which is understandable but
unproductive but there's a growing amount of people that are
like normal that are like getting really tired of the extreme
of like partisansship. They're like looking for normality and
I think that we see it by like how institutions are like somewhat
soft correcting towards like being less extreme about things.
We're seeing increasingly that like more like Libby based content
creators and Libby based takes are like getting more popular
again. I think there's like a there's an issue on the internet
where you have like not just the dead internet of bots but also
the loud internet which is like the most deranged people whereas
most people who are like listening to the internet like when
>> the dead internet of bots but there's also the loud
internet of people.
For no rational reason this contest has me off many such cases.
You got a shout out from none other than Oh god, I don't want
to pull this up on stream right away. I saw him replying in one
of the
Why is he funny? That's not my fault that he's funny. Okay, I'll
pull it up because it is funny. But it's not my fault. I'm not
I don't co-sign this person. They are unfortunately funny. Okay,
the commentary community needs mo more than anything is a conversation
between Queen and Nicholas. I think what the commentary community
needs most is a firing squad. I listen not unlike with the not
unlike with the queen takes.
give me you have to criticize him. Okay, you have to actually
criticize the point. Tell me where he's wrong first. Okay, you
got to tell me where he's wrong. Unhinged. That guy's unhinged.
>> How often do comments on YouTube? >> Totally disavow
that comment while it is funny. Totally disavow. No, none of
these people need to be shot or heard in any way. >> No,
not very often. >> Very rarely. And usually when I do,
it's because I'm like, "This was amazing."
>> Right. And so you have to be like a next level of like
untypical to be like leaving negative comments, let alone leaving
like multiple negative comments. And so I think like it's really
important that the people who are like lurkers essentially like
that's that's like 80%. >> Oh, this is the Oh, we're missing
her whole cope on why it's like she's she's like, "Oh, you only
get comments from people who like want to be negative, right?
Those are the only people who comment online. So lurkers need
to actually participate." >> How often do you comment on
a YouTube >> Yeah. No, not very often. >> Very rarely.
And usually when I do, it's because I'm like, "This was amazing.
Exactly. Right. And so you have to be like a next level of like
untypical to be like leaving negative comments, let alone leaving
like multiple negative comments. And so I think like it's really
important that the people who are like lurkers essentially. >> All
of the people who leave negative comments on my videos are mentally
ill. I actually believe this. Okay. I I hold this position as
well, Kyla. All of the people who leave negative comments about
me in my chat, um in Discord, on the internet, anywhere, those
people are mentally ill losers or bots. Okay? Okay. And the people
who say nice things about me are mentally thriving. Okay. Well,
like in totally fulfilled human beings. All right. That's just
how it is, guys. That's how we think about these people. >> Like
that's that's 80% of your audience.
has made his final support to your >> Okay. Well, thank
you, Inc. Man, appreciate it. >> In your chat like hammering
away because they throw it on in the background to support you
while they're like driving home or they're like chilling out.
And those people have to realize that like you have power, but
you have to be somewhat active enough. Not not as much as the
crazies, just active enough that the 80% of you drown out the
crazies. And the issue is that like a lot of normies are like
nervous. Like they don't double click to like things. They don't
like engaging comments and stuff. Just literally >> uh
Jog and if they join your stream, they're mostly they're the
most winningest people ever. It's just true. I mean, a lot of
these people
I I just like when people join, man, and they have criticisms,
but I get it.
I get it. Not a lot of criticisms of me to be had. I understand
>> like, "Hey, I really appreciated this." Like literally
or thumbs up. Just Just put the thumbs up emoji. Okay. And all
of a sudden, all the like crazy partisansship that we're seeing
on social media is going to get flooded out by just like people
who don't typically leave comments because most people are like
busy. Like I don't comments. I get it. But if we want to like
see a social media correction where like normal takes off, then
we have to actually train and facilitate the algorithm for that.
>> this is actually probably smart. I don't believe this
is true, but it's actually probably smart to do to say to like
make it so your audience feels a moral imperative to comment
and like your stuff, right? Guys, I want you to know that actually
Donald Trump will seek a third term. Unless you like all of my
tweets, you retweet them. Okay? Unless you're retweeting all
of my tweets, liking them all, constantly posting my clips everywhere
you can, Donald Trump will win a third term. Do I do politics
content that's broadly critical of Donald Trump? I do, but not
that often. Okay. How does it fight against him? How does it
help the world be a better place? I can't really explain that
to you either. But I do understand and you should understand
that it is critical to human thriving for you to like and retweet
and boost all of my clips, comments, everything. Okay, thank
you. >> Everyone's like the algorithm. I'm like, master
diabolical evil. >> World War II happens if we don't watch
JTOK. Yes, now you're getting it, Mia.
>> Billionaire plan. The billionaire plan is just what
gets engagement.
If you only listen and then some other weirdo leaves 90 comments,
unfortunately the bots kind of treat these things as the same
thing, right? So what you need to do is not just listen, like
leave one comment or like something. >> So in other words,
like, comment, subscribe, donate a galaxy, or you're a
>> No, but literally what she's saying is completely accurate.
What is happening is all the people who are normal, they just
see the post, they agree with it, and then they scroll on. They
do not interact with it, and it doesn't let the other far leftists
know that this is the popular opinion. So if you see a post from
like literally any of >> the the sleeping Trump voter,
okay, the shy Trump voter, but we have progressives talking about
it now. You love to see it >> or any normal liberal. And
it might be a >> begging for positive engagement is so
pathetic.
Ah, I don't know about that. I think it's good for people to
say, "Hey, it's helpful for you to engage with me this way."
But it should be clear that it's like it's helpful for me for
you to engage that way. If you want to help me, I don't try to
make it, hey, if you guys if you guys want Trump to be stopped,
if you want our political movement to succeed, it's critical
that you like everything I do, okay? If you want the world to
be a better place, you need to like my stuff. You need to retweet
it. You need to boost it in any way you can. That just seems
disingenuous. I want you guys to help me make money so I can
keep making content. And that's why you should donate or subscribe
or whatever the it is. Like, retweet, whatever the it is, okay?
Cuz I want you to help me. I want I want my community to get
bigger. I want more reach. I want more money. It's entirely self-interested.
>> Take. Yeah. Or a normal conservative. And it might be
like a hot take. Just like it. Show your support. If you actually
support us or support like like not hyper woke liberals or like
whatever it is, just normal people. Give them support by giving
them likes. Give them comments. Share out their cuz if you don't,
then the crazies on both sides win every time. Cuz those people,
that's all their life. All they do is sit on this app and wait
for the extreme psycho to pop off so that they can comment all
the negative stuff as possible. And that is why that it's that's
why it's >> And most people are going to comment on the
crazy stuff. Like if there's something that they don't agree
with, if it's something that's just outlandish, of course you're
going to comment on it. It's almost like a provocative kind of
piece of content that you're going to want to >> I just
think, listen, the the crazy people just tend to be funnier.
Okay. >> I follow Howling Mutant. I follow uh is it Ary
Harasaka? Aryan, I follow all of these accounts, okay? Because
they're just funnier. The unhinged people are just funnier. It's
not my fault. All right. That's And that's why they comment because
they know they can be >> It's rage fate. Exactly. So why
would you comment on something? You're like, "Oh, yeah, I agree
with that. Okay, keep on." That is how you keep seeing this crazy
[__] because you're you're engaging with that stuff
and it's also being perpetuated through the entire
>> Keep with the normals. Stop with the crazies. If you
see just like normal liberals engaging in goddamn normal
uh hell yeah ideas just like engage with us. It helps a lot and
I think that's one of the biggest problems is all the normal
people who like for example do you just like comment on every
post you see. No I don't either when I don't agree with it more
often than not. >> All the normal people do not comment
and that's the problem is like the support for normal people
supporting normal people is not presented whatsoever.
This could be true,
but I again I just can't I can't like ignore the clear clear
self-interest at play here, right? Like they have no reason to
actually believe this or to say this and believe it. They could
just want money, which is just >> because normal people
don't comment on normal people do not have the time. We don't
waste our time just commenting on everyone's [__]
>> That's like that's your incentive to do weird like things
that are going to drive interaction. >> Wait, do normal
people watch this kind of content? I don't know if they do. >> Yeah.
Like I'm gonna say something that's really weird because I know
that I'm gonna get likes from >> Okay, Sophia, you're the
one one normal person who watches. Okay,
>> It's like rage baiting comments. >> Have you guys
seen the Invisawware rage bait [__] Crazy. Oh my
god. Okay, so there's this company called Invisawware. But that's
actually a really cool service where it basically connects them
to like first responders. They don't know which is and then instead
of making normal ads like yeah if you guys like no I don't want
to. And he's like oh you're so [__] YouTube weirdo
guy off camera. He'll be like hey baby you want to go home tonight?
And Toby like no I don't want to. And he's like, "Oh, you're
so freaking I want to sleep with you." And she's like, "You're
being really weird." But it's the same. I watch your channel.
And it's all the same. And the whole point of it is to >> is
Nick there insults to leave comments and then all of the comments
can normal be like, "Look at all these insane. The comments look
at these insane men being like, right, which is just to be clear,
weirdo, right?" But they'll see this. They don't see they don't
put ad on their videos right now, which I think is illegal, but
it's still one of the things like I'm so grateful in where like
she always drops that line. So you always know and I'm like,
"Oh my god, oh my god, it's all fake." They're rage baiting incels
to get the video popularity so that normal women look at the
comments of the incel like maybe I'm doing invis like Jesus.
Holy [__] It's It's insane. It's It's the same that
the red pill did the man versus bear. >> Do you know what
happened with that >> No. They just clicked bear was wild.
>> Yeah. They just clicked out normal women who entered.
Well, not the few women who said and they clicked out all the
normal women who obviously because >> Oh, wait. Did a lot
of Okay.
Did that really happen?
I feel like is that not just the like the product of the the
gender divide online that women would say the bear? I don't feel
like it was intentionally just the red pill people. I don't know.
This is like also is that not just a like an actual behavior
of everybody online. I'm going to focus on the most unhinged
people I disagree with, right? You're never going to focus on
the most hinged person on the other side of the political aisle,
the the person who makes like good points. You're never going
to focus on them, right? Like why would you focus on let's say
out of progressives, why would you focus on Sam Cedar when you
go to Hassan or you could go to Frogan, right? It's way easier
to go to Frogan and have her say insane
and and just clip that and use it. So I think this is just a
general social media behavior. >> Social media scare is
so yes lady and being like we have to support women no matter
what they say. They just everyone started like retroactively
being like actually statistically speaking bears are great citizens
>> She's saying that the red pill astroturf the man versus
bear discussion by only quote tweeting the people who said the
bear thing and all the normal women cuz so many normal women
just said man there cuz so many normal women participate regularly
on Twitter, right? So, they all said man, but actually we just
the red pill people only quote tweeted or clipped out the people
who said bear and then they pretended everybody said bear. It's
like I I don't know. I think people probably just took the most
incendiary comments like always. >> We don't need to make
this argument. Nobody would pick the bear and be in the elevator
with them. They would obviously pick the man. And yes, is bad
and we should find better ways to criminalize because we are
vastly undisturbing victims. Like oh my god, all these things
can be true at the same time and you don't need to do the red
pill. You don't need to make
me a basic understand what they're trying to do.
>> Someone is asking someone is asking if Z took $300,000
from what the thing about Z is Z literally paid for us and our
hotel and our food and our breakfast and our gas and our rental
and everything. >> Oh well, guess what? Allison is noting
this all down. Okay, Z's paying for all of this stuff. She's
going to want to know where that shows up in the budget. Okay.
Show me where that shows up in your in your uh what would you
call it? Uh
I guess just your your budget. I was going to say some finance
term, some uh accounting term, but I don't know much about it.
>> That we could imagine she paid for so that us liberal
creators >> ledger. Sure. >> That's what I was wondering.
The thing is Z Coen Sanchez >> I just about said profit
loss and I was like that's not where that would go. literally
owns a company in which her whole entire job is to be paid by
political figures in order to do canvas projects for them. So
she gets paid for that. But then on the other side of that, she
is running the America tour out of her own charity. Of course,
she has a business as a political operative. Like that's not
that's not new information. People >> Oh, so this would
be Allison talking to them about it. Okay. >> Understand
how political campaigns work. Okay. They don't
>> I need people to understand how political campaigns
work. We're going to get some gems right here. >> Oh, how
political campaign work. >> So, you remember when everyone
freaked out about the $20 million like men speaking with American
men campaign that was happening on the left? I don't think people
understand. >> No,
I don't remember that at all. >> Trump spent $20 million
on young men in 3 months. Okay. When we're talking about $300,000
for a political campaign, I'm sorry, you're talking about baby
numbers in the politics world. And yeah, I would agree that's
[__] up. Don't look at this cuz we don't get that
much money, guys. We only get 300,000. That's that's ittyttty
bitty numbers in the politics world. Don't look at my stuff.
You You take less money, you you don't get investigated. That's
what I >> But that's not like a Z criticism. The criticism
is actually how the did she m if if she used only $300,000 to
make America as viral as it did, which it probably cost her way
less. If she did that, that might be the most politically effective
funded program that has ever existed, which probably isn't even
true. It probably >> What did America do other than have
controversy around how ineffective America was?
What What is America done?
There's like what is it like 12 debates on Destiny's channel?
Is that what it's done? I I said 12. I don't even know. They
had some Trump supporters come up or something. I just have no
idea. Let's just ignore why it became viral. Yeah, I don't like
>> grassroots and it's definitely cheaper than they're
even saying, but nobody nobody has a scope of what we're talking
about when we talk about money. We're talking about like $270
million. Okay, >> so we didn't we didn't hear about how
political campaigns work, right? We didn't hear any of that.
All we heard was this isn't even like a lot of money, so you
shouldn't worry about it. I didn't hear how the campaign worked,
why they spent money the way they did, why they funneled, you
know, 55% of their tonal or sorry, their total funding into Z's
private company. I didn't hear that. I just heard, well, this
is not very money or this is not very much money. God damn it.
I need to stop reading while I talk. Me, you ever read while
you talk? I'm trying to read chat and talk at the same time.
raised $1,000 for the America Tour event and I raised $850.
The entire event was ran off of no one else raised a single goddamn
dollar. Zo and Sanchez pays out paid out of her own company and
out of like the past donations of the last tour for us to be
able to do what we did today. We >> What did they do?
I actually should go and see like what they did like what the
positive outcome was of what they did. you were the only one
who had money raised like that what is that $1,850
and she said
>> yeah she she said she said it we're going anyways so
how's that not based I don't know can you >> so that could
all be valid that could be very valid I actually don't know okay
I don't know how they're spending money but like that's the question
is why is it going through this private company it seems like
kind of odd that all the stuff's going through the private >> guys
name a single other liberal operation or liberal pack or liberal
organization that pays for a ton of liberal content creators
to get into one place to debate conservatives, pays for breakfast,
pays for hotels, pay
>> this is none of this is saying that the money is being
spent well or that it's like uh effective. You're just saying
that these people I'm defending these people cuz they made my
life really cool. They like paid me a bunch of money. They they
paid for me to be here. They paid for my breakfast. They paid
for me to stay in the hotel. They're paying for me after this
to to drink and and sit on a sit in a hot tub and do a live.
Okay, these people are really cool. Who else would give me this
money?
I don't I don't know if she realized that's not an argument that
something good is happening. Who else would give me this money?
Uh I don't know. I That's That's a great question.
Why is somebody giving you this money?
They invaded right-wingers IRL with worse video and audio quality
than it if they did it online remotely.
Yeah, that's believable. >> Pays for rentals, pays for
flights, pays for all that cuz it doesn't exist. >> Well,
it does. It just costs eight times
>> Unless it's Republican. Unless >> Unless it's
Republican. >> They just throw it out. >> And I was
I was a conservative. I know. >> Don't Democrats raise
significantly more money than Republicans? >> I I got to
>> outside of Elon Musk coming in and dumping his own money
in to try to to force the election. >> The conservatives
will pay you well. This is the first person I've ever found who
actually cares enough
to spend her own money on us. And that is in >> Wait, she's
not spending her own money on you. She fundraised herself, right?
Like she had money dropped into America. I'm pretty sure. Right.
Am I crazy? I thought it was dropped into America. Like they
they fundraised themselves. They had funding from another place.
Do we have to go and look this all up? Cuz I could have sworn
from that balance sheet they had like funds allocated to them,
right? through donations and stuff. And then out of those funds,
55% of that was going into Soul Solutions, which is Z Coen Santis'
private entity, which could be fine. I don't know how these things
generally work, right? That could be actually fine, but it also
could be suspicious.
>> But But you aren't liberal, though. Are we Are we not
liberal? >> Yeah, I think we're pretty liberal. >> I
mean, yeah, obviously we're >> No, we're liberals. You're
just mad cuz we're not far crazy leftists.
>> That we're trying to change >> based. Someone
like named themselves based and then they said we aren't left.
>> Why would you name yourself based if you're not actually
based? >> You need to change that name. >> The issue
is that left is that political spectrum that the left is only
like a 10% amount because that's the only group that's allowed
to be merely morally pure, right? Look at Revelations. What is
it? 120,000 get to go to heaven. The left are doing the exact
same behavior,
the leftists are just like God and revelations.
Only 120,000 people are pure enough to make it to heaven to be
raptured. I don't even know what
what is
why is that connected? Is it like
by being exclusive you force people to come in your direction?
I don't think most people go far left. I don't know. this seems
like a >> where they lose all of the spectrum and they
go, "Well, everyone right of me can't be left because I'm special
and left is morally good." So, it has to be the case that only
I'm left and everyone left of me is left. It's like I'm sorry,
the political spectrum doesn't make sense. If 90% of people are
right, that just that's not how the compass works. It's a normative
compass. It's a normative compass. >> Someone said uh you
>> it's a normative compass. >> Capitalism is not
left.
>> It absolutely is. The the Soviet Union used markets
too.
>> I So hold on. I did not hear that comment. One second.
>> Someone said uh you defended capitalism. It's not left.
>> It absolutely is. >> The Soviet Union used markets
too.
>> Wait.
Is like any amount of market force capitalism? Maybe it is. I
don't know. Generally, when people talk about capitalism, they
mean like uh like fairly deregulated, very little government
intervention. That that tends to be >> Nick thinks he owns
with that one. Well, you you like kind of can't if you don't
have some kind of internal market, I think you basically can't
buy and sell anything. Like it's if the government had to do
all of it, I think the government as a central planning force
can't handle all markets that exist, right? So, some things have
to actually be open markets. >> We're just normal liberals
in a hot tub. Just because you regret voting for Trump doesn't
make you left or liberal. Except no one voted for Trump. >> Literally
nobody.
>> God did make you left or liberal. We're just normal
liberals in a hot tub. >> Just because you regret voting
for Trump doesn't make you left or liberal. Except no one voted
for Trump. >> Yeah. What the I'm Canadian. >> I'm
Canadian.
Wait, what? Why are you so invested in this? Have we Have we
done should somebody should do just a full back and forth on
Aerodite going from like politics is incredibly important. I
don't care about politics. Politics is incredibly important.
I don't care about politics. Actually, I'm not going to do politics
anymore. I don't care about politics. No, politics is incredibly
important. Can we go back and forth along this?
It's uh it's jarring. >> Literally, nobody. >> She
didn't She didn't vote. Wait, what did you vote? Nobody. >> I'm
a Canadian. >> You're a Canadian. They didn't vote. I voted
for Kla Harris. You voted >> I voted for Kla.
>> I'm a I voted for [__] >> So, we have
four commlas and two
>> Who voted for Carney? Hey, but isn't it
>> It's four commas. >> Four commas. >> Four
commas and two Canadians. >> More importantly, I just want
to be super clear. I don't need to prove my purity to you. All
we need to do is make liberals more effective. Liberals have
to support cows, which they're increasingly not. And we can just
forget about your opinion. All you're telling me is that politicians
will never need to pander to you because you're useless. I have
run liberal
events and I've run leftist events and I got to tell you guys,
you guys showed up to canvas. You were too social anxious to
knock at the door. You barely came. You were more expensive and
you were useless. When the liberals came out to knock, we knocked
40 like 43,000 door. >> She's making fun of everybody who
went to that NYC event. By the way,
that's what she's doing. She's comparing the New York City event
to the other ones where it was like Destiny and Co. That's what
she's doing right now.
Dude, this is uh this is very interesting. They're taking it's
like, okay, purity testing me to your end of the spectrum. Cringe
and gay. Purity testing you to my end of the spectrum. Awesome
and based. Very cool.
>> Also, allegations come out of every leftist event, too.
>> Someone said Mercedes, you're >> what is that
like hotel at TwitchCon? Would that be a leftist event? Would
that be a leftist event?
>> Just going to let her slur back there. Who said >> wait,
didn't Progressive Victory have allegations come out of their
canvasing house, too? Am I crazy? I know I heard some stuff about
the first Progressive Victory event, people who brought drugs
there and were like being weird to people. I know I heard about
this. I know for a fact I did. Who was telling me about it? It
was one of the PB It was like one of the first PB houses, I
I'll I'll have to think about it.
>> was it? No, it was not Darius being weird. And by the
way, also was just it was not I'll say I don't believe it was
like really strong allegations. It was like these guys are like
doing drugs and being weird.
That's like what it was. It wasn't like a real allegation, but
I'm just saying that having allegations doesn't matter, especially
if they're not tangible enough to bring forward in any way. >> Oh
my god.
>> Wait, hold on. Hold on. No, no. She She has the past.
She has a brain injury. >> She has Canadian. >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> I was raised by fundamentalist cop dad, so I feel
like I earned it. I've got my >> Oh, yeah. >> I don't
think you belong here if that bothers you either. >> TBI
TBI drop, guys. We got a TBI reference. Take a shot. Every TBI
reference, you take a shot until you're as mentally impaired
as Kyla herself. Okay? We take a shot at every TBI >> Yeah,
guys, for the base liberals, I know Tik Tok is not like we are
coming to take over Tik Tok. All of us, including not so aerodyite,
>> is going to take over the Tik Tok space and we're going
to introduce a group of people who are normal, who you can relate
to, who isn't going to purity test you and make you walk on goddamn
eggshells. And someone said in New York. >> In New York.
>> I don't know what that means. that for >> Hopefully,
it's an incorrect doc.
>> I'm sure it's a reference to a >> something
question. You're coming to New >> Is there any positive
comments you're going through?
>> This one says, "You are embarrassing right-wingers and
you lost your own
>> Except you haven't even seen the debates cuz they're
not posted yet. >> You guys couldn't take over a paper.
>> Embarrassing. Embarrassing rightwingers would be a >> a
good thing. So, what the [__] was that comment supposed
to mean? >> No, we are rightwingers.
>> Right wingers. Apparently, we're >> Good you.
>> We watched the live. Which live? Gracie. Oh, it's Gracie.
>> And we're making more money. >> I'm sorry, but
Destiny got late. Like, Destiny slay hard. He did a great job.
He did. He did. He did great. >> Also, like 16 hours. It
has like 16 hours of debate from >> Yeah, Destiny debated
for a long time.
>> He does. Someone left saying he got so cooked. It's
because you guys hate us and you hate the tour. Like, you guys
are always going to disagree with everything that we do as you
cry that trans people are losing the ability to get the correct
gender marker on their passports because
>> Is this just Is this a big talking point? the gender
marker on the passport. Is that like a big thing? Trust me, if
your big criticism of the current administration is that people
can't get the right gender marker on their passport, you're losing
the next election. You're going to find a way to fumble the 2022
midterms if you pick talking points like this. It's so
>> Because Donald Trump won and then you sit here and criticize
us who want to build electoral power to make sure people like
Kla Harris or andor the next >> I feel this is a woo tweet.
I'm almost positive it's a woo tweet. I'm positive it is. >> Whoever
runs wins. So, it just doesn't make sense. >> The thing
that the right does absolutely significantly better than the
left is they don't engage in this like purity test. Oh, you you
kind of align with me. Open arms. Like you get all the hugs you're
allowed at all like all the dinners and it's like we love you.
>> Yeah. Where's our toy gab? >> We don't exist.
Never could. >> We don't have we don't have that. It's
like we just everybody >> crazy cuz the job of politicians
is to
they're supposed to represent their constituents which means
that they come to understand what their constituents want and
then they represent that which is like definitionally grifting,
right? That's what you want politicians to do. And Tulsi Gabard
could grift, right? and the greatest job promotion she's ever
taken. It would never happen on the web because we would rather
be pure than win things, which is just
so it's not just that, right? It's like this is literally all
they talk about. Uh they switch topics sometimes. I'll be honest.
I'm just messaging people to see like uh who's going to come
on later in the night. So, it's nice to have this on in the I
am listening. I am like tuning in, but occasionally I tune it
out as well. >> We would rather be pure than win things.
We would rather be pure than save trans people's lives. We Oh,
are they doing they're doing the Hassan bad thing again, right?
Yeah, it is a lot of Hassan bad. I understand it's a lot of Hassan
bad. Guys, don't you know the far left like purity tests and
when we do this when we when we let them purity test, we actually
ruin our entire party. Also, it's really important we get trans
people the right gender on their passports right now. That's
what America's really worried about. These are the big issues,
guys. Not tariffs, not epsy, not anything else. It's just about
trans people and the gender marker on their passport.
which by the way could be a fair point, but it's just not something
you want to market on. >> We would rather be pure than
shave reproductive rights. We would rather be pure than, you
know, prevent fascism from taking over the country.
>> Okay, he's done his This is He's done his face twice
now.
This his face. I just owned you in the marketplace of ideas.
>> Sorry, I need to I need to grab that real quick. Oh,
>> I didn't see what that donation was, but thank you.
Whatever that was. Okay. I didn't see what it was. >> We
don't want fascism. We want to save trans people's lives. And
the problem is that like the left is purity testing. For one,
the left is hold no like electoral power. We just want to be
able to build a reality in which like obviously we're going to
clean at midterms. That's no. But if we clean at midterms and
then lose the next election, we're always >> uh Space Ghost.
Thanks for the gifted >> We always clean at midterms. Exactly.
literally always educated and like higher income people vote
in midterms which tend to trend left because reality trends left.
The issue, the real issue to like ignore the annoying leftist
is essentially all of the normal people who are actually fundamentally
the principally left want to abandon it because you guys are
embarrassing, right? But that I guess not to speak to the embarrassing
people to speak to every everyone else. There is a left movement
that is starting that actually like cares about the things that
we're talking about that wants effective policy that like wants
to allow people to exist by and large but not do evil, right?
We don't hate black people. Redlinining was obviously bad. We
want to be able to do things like >> No way. That's an
erate talking to a black person and immediately goes to this
person wants to hear about how I'm not racist. Yeah, >> raise
black. >> I bet this black person is very concerned about
redlinining in the year of our lord 2025. Okay, she needed to
hear that redlinining is bad. Definitely 100%. Guess what, guys?
Aeronites found the solution to the 2026
midterms. All right, we just need to tell black people that redlinining
was bad. We got it. >> Black people up. We want to do things
like help trans people get their rights. We believe in all of
these things and we don't care about the rest. We like want fundamental
human values. And if that >> we we don't care. We care
about black people, trans people, and we don't care about the
rest.
Okay, hold on. That has to be me being super bad faith right
there. She said some other stuff. >> We don't hate black
people. Redlinining was obviously bad. We want to be able to
do things like raise black people up. We want to do things like
help trans people get their rights. We believe in all of these
things and we don't care about the rest. We like Bro, this is
the most transparent pandering I've ever seen in my entire life.
Black person, black trans person, white trans person. We care
about not redlinining, not being racist, getting trans people
rights, and we don't care about the rest. Dude, that must be
what the TBI is. She actually doesn't have long-term memory.
She only has like 30 seconds of memory retention. The black This
is like one of This is one of six people she knows. The people
in the hot tub. Okay. She's like, "Black people are really important.
Trans people are really important. We got to we get this messaging
out here right now." >> Like want fundamental human values.
And if that's something you want to get behind, nobody gets to
rob you of your label. Leftists don't get to take my label from
me. They don't get to take my principles. It I'm sorry. I'm left
because I believe in it principally. It doesn't matter if you're
a piece of that doesn't like it. It's my fundamentals. And I'm
sad that the group that I want to associate with is so embarrassing,
but I will associate with it anyways because I believe in it.
>> dude. Everyone in this pool is cool with Z. So if you
have a problem with Z Yeah. If you have a problem with Z, you
have a problem with all of us.
>> Literally that part. >> I suggest you let that
one marinate. >> You took ours so I can take your yours,
little girl. Wait. Take what? That's crazy talking. She said
she said she said I can take yours so you took our so I can take
yours little girl >> labels. I don't know that. What is
that? >> This is talking about like she was saying like
you don't get my label from me. I'm assuming that it's in the
context of well you took my label from me so I'm going to take
your lab. >> The thing is she didn't >> that's to
herself. All she did is she has a business. She has a business.
Of course the money is going to be held in a business account.
I do not understand. Okay. When you say that Z >> I don't
think they understand how entities work. >> Oh wait wait
wait. She she's going to she's going to explain some accounting
>> I do not understand. Okay. When you say that Zo
>> I don't think they understand how entities work like
they keep saying Ziko and Sanchez had $300,000
sent to like soul strategies where else would it be sent where
is it supposed to go in like someone else's bank account like
who else? So, at a base level, I don't really know, but I could
understand how somebody with a rudimentary understanding of accounting
and and not a lot of experience could think, hey, if I'm running
a nonprofit whose books are open because it's involved in politics,
then probably if they send most of their money to a corporation
with possibly like uh would opaque be the right word here? Yeah,
like obfiscated books, that might be bad. Like that company now
might be paying everybody and actually we don't know where the
money is going anymore because it's gone to some corporation,
right? that could be considered bad. And I don't know what the
rules are there. So for me, I'm just
this looks weird. Could you explain it? That's I think I think
that would be probably what their criticism is. And that might
not be a valid criticism or there might be rules around it that
Z's like right on the edge of. I don't know. But like they're
not actually engaging. They're like, "No, it doesn't sound weird
that they send all that money to the corporation." Well, how
do you how can you say that?
It seems like their criticism is possibly like bounded. At least
in terms of like your intuition, the criticism seems okay. But
if it's if it's so transparently bad, then you should be able
to say why it's bad.
>> Cohen Sanchez had $300,000
sent to like Soul Strategies, where else would it be >> Where
is it supposed to go in like someone else's bank account? Like
who else's bank account would it go into? >> Mad Charlie
Kr getting the money he gets. No, they don't give a They are
so mad that a tour that is going to >> Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa. Hold on. Are these guys talking about Turning Point
The The organization that gets the most money from Apac, not
AFPA, Apac. Okay. That is like Israel's closest ally in American
political fundraising or political organizing that literally
sends people on trips to Israel. That includes that stuff. It
sounds like if you want if you want people to look into Charlie
Kirk and and Turning Point's money, that might be a little bit
anti-semitic.
Okay, we heard Aerodite break that talking point out last night
that the questions about Z were actually because it's a a business
run by a woman. Okay, and I'm going to flip it on them. Charlie
Kirk, that's one of the most pro-Israel businesses that exists,
Turning Point USA. Are you really going to criticize Turning
Point USA? Well, I wonder what your motives might be. debate
conservatives exist and nothing else exists like this except
what we're doing and they want us to be able to combat Republican
culture except they won't support it because it's not purity
tested enough for themselves and I'm just like holy she is the
only liberal that exists that is willing to pay for like every
single thing that we do at the price she like she's she's based
>> she couldn't possibly be doing fraud she gives me money
she makes my life awesome
how could she be doing fraud she makes my life awesome dude There's
no reason. There's literally nobody else who would give me money
to come and sit in a hot tub and get drunk and talk on Tik Tok.
Doesn't that explain to you exactly how she is not doing something
weird when she's the only person who will pay for me to do this?
Don't you understand?
Z's got to just be like, "Hey, don't ask don't answer questions
about me. Don't talk about me on your streams, okay? Just say
you don't know. Please just say you don't know cuz when you guys
talk about me, you make it sound like I'm doing some insanely
shadyit.
Please just say you don't know. Just say you don't know. Say
send an email busy or something. Okay. Thank you. >> Hey.
And she cares about us. I don't know why that's such a problem.
>> Someone said you like
look at you defending the grip. It's not that I'm defending.
There's no grip here >> It's so simple. If you think she's
doing something illegal, you can report it to the IRS and they'll
look into it. And I'm going to >> If she is If she is,
they'll figure it out. Otherwise, don't worry about it so much.
I don't know. Like, >> okay. Apparently, you would check
with both the IRS and the FC here, but to me, when you're talking
about political funding and misuse, mismanagement, misuse of
political funds, that's the FEC.
You go to the FC, the Federal Election Commission. And I don't
know why you're I don't know how you could be that involved with
uh politics and political organizing as Aerodite has been, and
not mention the FC here for where the complaint where complaints
could go.
The issue to me is that when people are like talking about this
like this money stealing for example, if anyone who politically
aligned with you perfectly had done the same thing, you wouldn't
give a right. This is what we're talking >> This political
money stealing >> anyone who politically aligned with you
perfectly talking about this don't worry about it so much. I
don't know. Like the issue to me is that when people are like
talking about this like this money stealing for example, if >> this
money stealing, if you're talking about this money, >> people
politically align >> if people politically aligned with
you and were doing fraud, you would just look the other way,
right? Wouldn't you just look the other way? If people politically
aligned with you were doing fraud, guys, >> with you perfectly
had done the same thing, you wouldn't give a, right? This is
what we're talking about. When I mean principles, when I mean
principles, I say when people break the law, I think that that's
bad. and I report it to the proper institutions because I believe
in our institutions by and large even though there's lots of
problems within them and I try to see if the institution does
it correctly and if it doesn't I speak out on it because the
institution
>> Yeah. What they're not understanding is Z owns like
a political operative
Soul Strategies is meant to do canvasing events where political
figures hire her to canvas. And >> so here's the issue.
Okay,
here's the issue. If you send a significant portion of your capital
to just one to just one consulting company that you also own,
then that that is potentially sending money that's supposed to
be tracked uh very transparently to a company where I don't know
if the books are open. Now, if all of soul uh what is it? Soul
soul strategies or soul solutions, whichever one it is. If all
of these companies books are open, it's like a nonprofit, they've
got totally open books or something, then maybe that's fine.
Uh can you watch my response to legal mindset? What's up, Alex
Neville? Um, yeah, I can, but you got to send it to me, bro.
I tried. You deleted it from your VODs. Sorry. Just real quick
aside here, guys. It's uh it's no longer in your VODs, and somebody
sent me an archive link, and that didn't work either. If you
if you have that up on YouTube somewhere, I could watch it, but
I need it up on YouTube. It's on YouTube now. Okay. Yeah, I will
watch it. Yeah, we watched uh we watched Legal Mindsets response
last night, so yeah, I'll definitely watch it. Thanks for letting
me know.
and she's running the America tour under the same pack. So they
think that all the money that comes in for these canvasing events
because like for example if you're doing mailers to 25,000 people
it's about >> yeah no problem man
per mailer and it comes out to like 20 something,000 and then
they get and it's just like
>> what happened with the excess money?
>> I don't know. I bet you for another
>> I need to hear what uh Nick's saying there. My bad.
Well, what what do they want to happen with the excess money?
>> I don't know. I >> They want to be spent on after
parties.
>> The No, no, no. That's the thing, though. The excess
money got spent on us. So, all the money from the last tour,
all the donations.
>> We only raised 1,800.
>> Does she think this is like
I don't know if this person understands the arguments they're
making at all. You guys don't understand. This is completely
in like this is completely
um below water. It is in the red heavily. There's no way that
we could pay for this ourselves. It doesn't make any sense for
them to use this money. Okay? We actually really suck at this.
We cannot fund raise. We cannot support ourselves at all to do
this. And so, you have to understand that they gave us money
for very little reason. And now they're paying this they're paying
us to drink and do Tik Tok streams. Like,
yeah, I I think we're starting to get why people feel weird.
>> $50 on this last tour. All the money from the last tour
was specifically
>> Yeah, Apollo's Heights. That's the thing is like I think
probably because Soul Strategies Z's business is something that
does organize campaigns and stuff. They probably know what the
limits are for how much you can send to one company and they
might even have totally open books anyway. Or they might file
reports with the FC. Like there's so many possible things they
could do to fix that problem that I have very little doubt they're
doing it. I'm just saying when when you don't tell people like
hey uh actually the money going to Z's company is fine because
she files this report this form that actually says she provides
like a ledger an accounting of exactly where she spent that money
and who she sent it to. But she files that back to the the previous
company so that they can include it in their reporting but the
the requirement for that is like lagging by a year. So in about
a year you'll go and figure that out. That to me, I just made
that up, but that seems like something that could entirely be
possible. But that's not what they're saying. They're saying,
"Don't you understand that this person's giving us money and
you should shut the up? Don't you understand that if fraud was
happening and it was by somebody who is politically aligned with
you, you wouldn't care? Like, they're making possibly the worst
arguments you could make for people to shut up and walk away."
I actually don't really doubt that Z's business is funded correctly.
I would assume so, right? You could look into it, but I would
assume so. Echos of PV. Yeah, it's it's a little different than
PV in some ways, but this was this was an issue with PV where
they were taking their money from their transparent pack, I think
their open pack, and they were funneling it through uh something
that was, you know, obfiscating how they were paying people out
and that was concerning and possibly a violation. But I don't
think this Z Coen Sanchez person, it's like a different group
of people with the money. I think this time I I feel like it's
probably okay, but hey, these people are going to file reports
or something and and figure out >> so that we could do
this Florida tour and they are mad about it that Z put money
aside to make sure that this tour could continue
>> I'm so proud of my >> I just also does this person
think that Z is putting that money aside like privately like
she took $50,000 of her own money was like I'm going to run this
event anyway. I Is that I don't know.
But if you thought that maybe you wouldn't have these opinions
if you didn't hate Destiny and were a misogynist, you criticized
Kyla. That's true. I actually if I if I wasn't obsessed with
Destiny and Kyla and hated them totally irrationally,
then perhaps
I would also not have any questions about potential fraud. True.
I hadn't thought about that.
>> Oh my god. I didn't know that we raised $1,000 cuz >> Yeah.
shoes. Okay. So, I try to tell the funders all the time, streamers,
they're worth investing into. Okay.
>> Invested in us. >> I'm so proud of you guys. Good
job. >> $1,000 to go disrupt Charlie Kirk. So, left us
be mad. And the funny part is, you know what my audience is?
>> Red Pill Young Men.
>> Well, not no not
>> just but also like educated
>> Red Pill Young Men. >> Dissident left and >> Wait,
is that who her audience actually is? I would say that describes
precisely like 0% of the people I've ever met who watch Aerodite.
I've met a lot of them. There's a lot of people like in my community
who used to watch Arerodite. There's like a ton of them. I don't
I don't know that I've met one that's like former Red Pill or
Red Pill >> moderates and some liberals. That's my audience,
right? It's like liberals, red pill men, uh, and like dissident
left who probably like were agnostic or voted >> That's
who funded this tour.
>> Isn't that wild? >> Do you think that dynamic
is a problem? like whole like money raising like if you think
that dynamic is a problem,
>> bro. Like look at the right
that is the >> they are funded by Russia and we're the
>> Yeah. And they don't they don't they don't hide it.
>> You know, it's not like it's not like we're trying to
keep this on the low or whatever. Like they're all about it.
They're like check how much money we've got. Look at how big
this convention >> Z absolutely knows that every single
person on TikTok will be looking into any of her FEC reports.
She knows that and she still files them and then submits them.
And that's like what I don't understand is my biggest. >> Okay,
this person knows what the FC is. Let's go. >> Is people
who want to see change, they want change. They are so upset that
Donald Trump won and then when a tour
>> I mean all you got to do is say, "Hey Z, people are
concerned that you're like filing through this corporation. Could
you just explain how you get transparency in like your funding
and how you spend it and could you just make a short TikTok on
it and then we could post that and then this criticism disappears.
It just dies, right? You just say exactly how you're doing your
funding stuff and then it we're all good
>> and they see like you guys ever see that graph or that
picture that's floating around with a bunch of like red circles
and then blue circles. We don't have that right and we are trying
to build that and these are the exact same people who want to
tear it down because they're upset because they don't like Z
Cohen Sanchez. And I'm like she's the only one who is actually
making something like this happen. >> You're shooting yourself
in the foot by these people. These people are what is preventing
us from like slipping. >> Um this is actually precisely
what Progressive Victory was doing. Z is not even the first person
to do this, right? You could say the counterprotesting thing
is a unique spin on it, going after turning point, but realistically
like I don't know how much they're they're catching the Turning
Point people anyway,
but this idea of like using streamers to advertise politically,
not new, not >> into like a worst form of society. It's
like the resistance that we have currently like is not a bad
thing. Just cuz it doesn't align with you 100%. It's like you
shouldn't be on these people because they're still advocating
for you and your position to a degree. It's like >> who
do you think would be a better steward of your rights? Somebody
who is on the right and is getting paid uh like by the same people
who are paying Charlie Kirk or the people who are on the left.
It's like who's doing a better job? Okay, then maybe don't [__]
on the people who are like >> all of them got banned from
even going to the Turning Point event, so it probably didn't
work out as planned. Oof. I'm sure Charlie Kirk is terrified
of these intellectual giants. Like I'm sure Charlie Kirk doesn't
want to debate people, right? I'm sure he doesn't want to debate
people who are like super informed cuz obviously dunking on people
makes you look good.
But yeah, I don't know. I I feel like these people counterprotesting
isn't going to do anything. They're not really putting pressure
on them. He just ignores them, right? I don't know if these people
will generate as much buzz counterprotesting Turning Point as
like Gropers did. Like Gropers put pressure on them. I don't
know if these people will. The Groper thing though that was like
um what do you call it? Decentralized like they weren't they
weren't identifying themselves before they went right. I think
the the this event could work if you were like broadly trying
to get people on TikTok to go and debate these things without
identifying themselves openly
>> advocating for your rights to >> Yeah. Go back
to the stream. They argue about the 10% right. We agree on 90%
of these things. Democracy, freedom, the rights that people should
have. But it's that 10% that they just want to blow up on. And
I don't understand why that's a >> Even if it was 40%.
Like we 40% agree with you and 60% disagree. It's like the other
side 100% disagrees with you. Why the are you like don't engage
in the security test.
>> No, Ally, I spoke to you. We spoke. But that's what
I'm trying to explain to you is like they all watched me speak
to you. They they heard me. >> Ian added some virality
to it and they had to keep it up. But now that faded and no one
wants to follow loser millennials on Tik Tok at least. I don't
even know if that's true. Um I think Andrew Wilson's kind of
crushing it on Tik Tok. But I don't think you like I don't think
the brand of debating that these people do does well on Tik Tok,
right? Like you watched you watch that Jaden guy come in and
just stalk a down in that debate and was like absolutely like
obliterating her on the points
and unfortunately he got derailed but like he was just calmly
debating. I don't think like the spuring out really works on
these people. Andrew Wilson also crushes OF creators on podcasts.
True. Yes. But I'm saying there's ways of engaging as like an
older person on Tik Tok that would work. I just don't know if
like this kind of debating works if like if this lane has a lot
of uh you know older people in it. I think there aren't a lot
of old conservatives on Tik Tok though talking to you. Like my
only problem cuz I do a lot of talk to text cuz the dyslexia.
My issue with with what you're saying is that I think that you
are separating
Z's
like actual soul strategies business that has existed before
she started the America Corp. >> No, when I say we spoke,
I mean we texted. That's speaking to me. That's
>> Everyone here knows that I talk to you and that I love
the [__] out of you. It's just like I think we have
a disagreeance on can you give me a single other liberal like
pack owner who is inviting content creators to an event to debate
to get immense amount of content dunking on conservatives
and is willing to pay for the whole entire thing
>> if she want does she have any pack info
>> I I like I I personally like so Allison is a leftist
and I actually love her she's like really cool >> like
my last year working with Democrats so she can have a comparison.
>> So,
uh, since you're friends, I'll be good faith. Actually, I'm usually
good. >> I love you, Alison. >> I'm usually good
faith. >> It's really important to understand my different
experiences. So, this is not an indictment of the company that
I worked with before. The company that I worked with before was
massively limited by the funders. The problem with the Democrat
space is that they >> Alison wants to join up. Would you
talk to her? >> Yeah, of course. >> Okay. Yeah. >> Let's
go. I knew that we were going to get that right before the end.
So, one a couple things we're looking for here is just overall
how does this start? How does it get heated towards the end?
Um, who calls the black woman a slur?
And and did they were they referring to everybody? Cuz I think
to Tashika should come in for this part, right? >> Join
up. >> We should get Tashika here. >> Let's go. Yeah,
I was going to say music down probably so that we can hear those.
>> We're about to have a a combo. Okay, guys. Ready?
>> Oh [__] >> Here we go.
>> Yeah. Allison was the person running the other stream
who like Aerodite was spering on and they had like a debate with
her and Tashika and the Jaden guy. So Allison was the person
whose VOD we watched yesterday and now she's about to join this.
This is the prelude to the stuff we had watched yesterday. >> I
like Allison. She's sweet. She doesn't like Z cuz Z sent her
cease and desist during the first during the first tour thing
but like I do like her.
>> She's really sweet. So be nice.
I'm biased towards women. I just like >> Oh, thank you.
>> Yeah. Um, no worries. Hey, what's up? >> Hey,
how's it going? >> Hey. Um, so yeah, I mean I so I was
looking through the finances. I noticed that 55 I think 23% of
the finances were going straight back to Soul Strategies. And
additionally, I don't know if Mercedes showed you to the rest.
There was a few highlighted businesses that I even tried to verify
to see if they were legitimate. I could not find that they were
legitimate businesses. I didn't see them on B.
Yeah, we saw that last night that Zia had served um had served
Allison in a cease and desist. Although I don't even know what
a CN would you see and D a Tik Tok account. I don't even know
where that information would be that she get a cease and desist
on something >> profile. I didn't see them being an established
business. One of them I even just saw a web page where you couldn't
even click anywhere else on the website. It just had a quote,
what it did, and then the address with no other landing
So, um, first of all, I'm not going to speak for Z's business
because I don't >> my my important question to you would
be if you think that like that an actual indictable business
fraud is going on, why wouldn't you just report it? >> I
did. I I sent a letter to the IRS >> So, then shouldn't
you kind of like let it be? And >> I mean, no, I I can
100% let people know that like 55% of the operating budget went
to her own business.
>> No, the issue >> I mean, and she only has Okay.
I mean, can I be clear? like they only raised they raised half
a million dollars. >> Okay, go ahead. >> Yeah. So,
I think the issue is that when we submit it to the authorities,
I'm sure you're aware the IRS is underfunded. So, it's going
to take a little bit for it to process. >> Obviously, it's
going to be a year. >> Sure. So, we should give them some
time to process it. But the issue is that what if what if by
any chance you were wrong? Even if it's 5%.
>> Why can't Z just come out and say this is what happened?
Or maybe Z did.
Why would Z dot just come out and say here's like why this is
happening? That's it seems like the question. Hey, why is 55%
of the operating budget going to Z's corporation? Z can just
come out and say this is why 55% of the operation operating budget
is going towards my corporation.
Boom. Done. Easy.
>> If I'm wrong, I would love that. I mean, so I do reconciliation
and auditing. When I'm when I'm looking through these receipts,
I'm not seeing them they're being targeted to anything direct.
>> Okay, let's just pause it, right? >> Okay. wrong,
you would you would like that, right? >> Uh yeah, just
a little bit more uh detail on what the funds are being used
for. Correct. >> Sure. The issue is that if if you're wrong
and you >> So again,
I thought so basically the thing I'd heard was Allison was like
unhinged here and accusing this person of fraud. She's just saying,
"Hey, I just want an explanation." And the response is, "Well,
if you're wrong, then isn't this really bad?" Like, no, I'm asking
for an explanation. you continue this campaign and you end up
being wrong and you harm what Z is trying to do. But more importantly,
>> is this going to be a talk about my danger level or
like the actual spending? Cuz I I mean I don't I have nothing
to lose here. Like I don't have anything to sue on like she sent
me a season to assist. I don't really care. Um are we talking
about the legitimacy of the spending or my risk? >> I'm
not I'm talking I'm talking about like let's think about like
the practicalities of this, right? Like the >> Well, I
mean so if we could go back to something important. I'm just
>> Dude, I Yeah, I can see.
Apparently, this isn't condescending, but
the person has a concern. You don't want to talk about that concern.
You want to shame them for being concerned.
Maybe they should be shamed for being concerned. I'm not 100%
sure yet. But if you actually just want to shame them for being
concerned, you should go, "You don't know what you're talking
about. Here posted exactly why we do this. You're a [__]
Leave. Bye. We don't want to talk to you." Mercedes, could you
pull up that list of verified businesses? I couldn't verify.
>> Not in the hot tub because I'm a wet. >> Okay.
All right. Fair enough. >> When we're talking about the
practicalities of how this plays out, right? You've reported
to the IRS, which I think that you should do, right? If you have
legitimate concerns about the spending of things, you should
just report it, right? And now at this point, it's in the hands
of the IRS. If you >> correct, which you guys still choose
to be affiliated with with public
If you continue to scam me and you end up being in I would >> you
continue to what? >> If you continue
>> if you continue to something me online. Hold on. I need
I need to turn this up. Audio is bad. >> At this point
it's in the hands of the IRS. If you continue >> correct
but you guys still choose to be affiliate. I >> I can't
I literally can't tell what it's saying. Scrutinize speaking.
I'll look at her lips and somebody >> is in the hands of
the IRS. If you >> correct which you guys still choose
>> assuming things online assuming things online assuming
I think >> should be affiliated with with public
if you continue
and you end up being incorrect and I would love that number one
I don't believe you if you would love that that would mean that
you would prefer it is the >> I don't want this to be true
anything wrong and I suspect you wouldn't want somebody who has
done nothing wrong to be socially punished for something. >> Well,
I mean, see, she did send me a cease and desist. Uh, that's kind
of why I'm involved in the first place. If you know anything
about that, I heard she regrets sending me that. Uh, which good?
>> You and again, I trust the courts to manage that. If
the cease and desist was false, the truth.
>> Okay. Uh, you can have concerns about things publicly
without like while you wait on the courts, right? Like there's
information out publicly, people will make their decisions. It
might not be fair, but unfortunately Z has not exactly managed
the optics around this well. Did she deserve like the hate she
got for the Dean Parker thing? No. Dean Parker kind of sued her,
but I don't think she's managed the optics around this very well
either. >> Send me a lawsuit after
>> if it was legitimate. Unfortunately, that's something
that you have to deal with as well, right? Unless >> I
understand, honey. Like this is like I understand what you're
saying outside of this. I can I speak to argue with me the
>> So, hold on.
>> That's pull back cuz I'm trying to see who's interrupting
you can deal with as well, right? >> I understand, honey.
Like this is like I understand what >> they're both getting
kind of >> outside of this. Can I speak? >> You want
to argue with me, but the institution's
bad. Do you think >> Yes, I understand. But
all you can do if you suspect something wrong happened is appeal
to the institution and never say anything else. Okay? Like for
example, if you were to make a public statement before filing
your civil lawsuit and then if you were to continue to pursue
that in any way publicly without just being like just operating
through the courts, that would be really bad. Okay? That would
be really bad. I really hate it when people don't trust the institutions.
You don't trust the courts. Stop letting this play out in public.
Okay? Just trust the institutions. Don't use information you
have available to you to make any deductions at all. Do not in
a controlled way, by the way. Do not don't do that. Just shut
up. Just shut up until the courts deal with it. >> I want
to talk about what like just national ground game pack. So I've
done a lot of digging in FC files. I've looked through other
Can I You haven't told I already told you >> I can't talk
about Z's finances. >> Wait, hold on. Someone said Z. >> Okay,
then is that not the point of me being up here? >> Hold
on. Hold on. Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z, do
you want to come up here? Z said, >> oh Z's here. So Z
can just come up and explain exactly why that is the case with
those finances and then it's easy. It's solved. By the way, Allison,
our sketchy business color, the color for is Mattiey's business.
He's our videographer. Yeah. And Matty was there. >> And
now it's for flight reimbursement. 6,000 for flight reimbursement
for a
>> That probably makes sense, right? So flight reimbursement
might include shipping stuff like uh doing super heavy camera
and video equipment to go over there, but I don't think the quality
was very good for what they paid. They probably should have tried
to find somebody local.
>> Z, do you want to come up here and talk to them? Are
you doing these interviews from white rightwing? >> She
she should not she should not come >> The issue is Allison.
>> I do. >> No, she should not come on. Okay. >> Auditing.
So, I understand reconciliation and how to actually file and
what you need to put your money towards and the >> Oh,
Allison seems like she's not a [__] then. Like like
Allison might actually have some idea of what she's talking about.
She might have looked up the forms that, you know, would let
that business explain how they were spending things and be transparent.
and I don't see that >> I'm going to grant you in this
conversation Alison that you know way more about auditing than
I do just so
>> which is why I've assumed that you've already gone to
the IRS which we've already established that you did so now there
are a couple of pathways that this can go right one of them is
if you believe in the institutions if you >> I think if
if this person is an accountant they're saying there's something
really wrong here
and there's some debate over whether something's really wrong
there then she can say this is what I think could be happening
and I don't want people to donate when it's when there's something
potentially sketchy going on here. Okay? I want people to donate
in that case. That seems totally fine, right? Because then Zeke
could come out and say, "No, no, no, no. This is what's happening
and obviously you're wrong. You don't have to just wait for the
institution." You could say, "This is my concern. This is how
like confident I am that this could be happening and it seems
weird that these people won't come out and clear this up for
us." That's totally fine. you believe that they are semifair
then the institution
will have the effect that you want it to. Correct.
>> And until then if you continue the campaign there's
two possibilities. In one case you continue the hate campaign
and like the negative campaign against
>> the hate campaign. It's an unhinged obsessed hate campaign
guys. If you continue the hate campaign against
and you are correct that she's defrauding and what would that
mean for you that you were right like the whole time, right?
>> I mean, so I don't, like I said, I don't want to be
right on this and I hope I'm wrong. I hope the IRS finds something
that I am incorrect cuz I really am disgusted. Like it makes
me physically ill to like see all this money um in in the way
that it's being broken out. Like I don't want this to be true.
I think you guys think that I just want to be like everybody,
you know, actually. No, >> I think the issue why I don't
believe that you think that this is true is because you're not
considering that if you are wrong and you are going to such a
social campaign and you were seeking it in this way and not waiting
for the IRS to do it. >> So I could see this Allison person
being unhinged and be like America has to go. They have to be
destroyed. I could see that. But why isn't saying that? Always
makes me concerned when they won't say what the person's doing.
An unhinged obsessed hate campaign. >> Okay. Instead of
actually saying what's going on. actually tell me what's going
on. Tell me what they're doing because they're being pretty polite
here and they're just saying, "Hey, this seems concerning to
me that things are being filed this way." That's totally >> process.
The issue is if you were wrong, you are now socially punishing
and harassing somebody and that's okay, but I want to be clear.
So the information I posted was most importantly and most importantly
damaging a movement. Oh my >> Actively actively trying
>> this what the left looks like. [__] >> to
push back against fascism and trying to bolster the left which
I think we would all agree is a good move. >> Are you are
you going to keep cutting me >> I'm only cutting >> guys.
We're fighting against fascism. It really feels weird that you
are looking at our bookkeeping and asking questions as an accountant
with auditing experience. Okay. It's really weird that you're
asking these questions when Donald Trump's the president. We're
we're fighting off fac uh when you are going on tangents that
I don't want to talk about. I've already told you I >> Okay.
Well, this is all public record on the FC and and anybody that
has done any auditing or financial experience in the past would
notice that these memos look really strange with only payments
of 25,000 and 50,000. That's all we're seeing. We're not really
seeing other payments like scentwise. That looks really strange
when we're looking at
>> again. Again, that's fine. You should submit this to
the IRS until >> Okay. And I did. It's
>> I mean and you guys just still don't choose to question
it and that's cool. You're allowed to but it's like I ask you
to verify. >> This actually seems like a totally like assuming
I assuming this person isn't misrepresenting themselves. Assuming
that they've looked at the rules that the FC has and they're
saying, "Hey, this is very inconsistent with a lot of other campaigns,
right? Like most campaigns do not do not dole out monies uh monies
in even amounts like this. Okay, even nice even 25 to like these
different things. seems odd. That seems like a wellfounded concern
that you can ask questions publicly about and not be like an
unhinged like evil person. Seems totally fine to me. And they're
not really being they're not being rude. They're not getting
like that heated as far as like a contentious conversation goes.
Is still pretty calm. >> It's fine. You should submit this
to the IRS and tell >> Okay. And I did. It's
>> I mean, and you guys just still don't choose to question
it, and that's cool. Well, you're allowed to, but it's like I
ask you to verify any of the businesses that I listed. Um, for
example, it's like Sunyama Strategies. That's the website that
has literally nothing but a homepage. You can't even click anywhere
else or email anybody. Um, I just ask you to look at the legitimacy
of the businesses that are like that money is being sent to because
I'm not finding
>> The issue the issue for me is that >> Hey, Z said
that that person you're talking about is our treasurer.
So the the the strategies that why do you say that Samayyama
strategies is our >> and so why are you sending 30,000
to your uh in why would that not be on >> Just she'll respond.
Give her a second to do an overunder when you both
>> Okay, this should be fine. Oh,
why is Ardite obfiscating? Arodite already said she doesn't want
to talk about this. The person wants to know what these companies
are. Z is answering. Why does Arodite feel the need to interject?
She's already said she doesn't want to talk about this specific
topic. If she interjects to talk about institutions again, I'm
going to blow my brains out. Figuratively, not literally, because
she's almost certainly just gonna say, "Well, shouldn't she just
trust the IRS >> Because again, if you've said this to
the institution, you trust the institution. If you believe that
the
was scaring her manager, >> I don't trust it though. I
unfortunately I don't trust like you guys. This the operation
that the foundation of this operation has not been >> You
don't need to trust me. I'm allowed as an adult to make a bad
decision. Right. It's possible that if you're right, I could
be making a bad decision. >> Okay. Yeah. >> Okay.
And
>> uh I don't feel bad about the what aboutism Destiny
was doing to her when she was trying to say like, "Hey, don't
you think it's weird to
dead kids?
Hey, don't you think it's weird to dead kids on Twitter?" And
he's like, "Well, what about Trump?" Right? I don't feel bad
for her anymore because she's now this person's like, "This accounting
seems very odd." And her response is, uh, shouldn't you be looking
at Charlie Cart's accounting? Um, would you actually, you would
be totally fine with this if it was people who are corrupt and
politically aligned with you? Actually, it's just the political
alignment that's your problem.
>> Make a bad decision. >> Correct. Yeah. All the
evidence has been given. I mean, this looks sketchy. You guys
just need to look into it. >> Sure. The issue is that people
allowed to take risks with regardless if they choose to or not
to. Yeah, dude. Z should message Aite personally and say, "If
you could do me a favor and never ever ever ever comment on my
businesses again, you are the worst optics imaginable. You are
the absolute worst optics imaginable. Shut the up about my businesses.
Never answer a question about it. Just shut your mouth." Jesus
>> Listen, people are allowed to take risks. Uh if this
business is doing fraud, well, I can see that they might be doing
fraud. Okay? If they're doing fraud, then that's my risk to take.
I'm an adult. Why are you Why are you getting mad? Who What's
the harm to you in me working with a company that does fraud?
What's the harm to you? Is there really harm? Is there harm in
letting the institution just handle this? >> Issue is that
people allowed to take risks regardless if they choose to or
not to. >> Yeah, 100%. Did I tell you you couldn't do this?
Did I tell you >> I'm really leaning on that soy voice
right now? I should probably stop doing that soy voice. Don't
Did I tell you you couldn't go debate in a sports bar and block
the camera for half of the time? >> I would say that if
your entire social media presence holistically is anti the campaign,
anti-z and pressuring and >> that's really not. If you
actually look at my page, I do a lot other than that my main
focus. >> Hey, this person's getting criticisms like I
do. I think it's weird how all of your Oh, I just did it again.
Sorry,
stupid. I think it's weird how all of your criticisms
are of Destiny and it's all of your content. It's like, hey bro,
it's like it's like 2% of the content. It's 2% of the content.
Can we not? Can >> That's all you guys choose to. >> Bro,
I am obsessed with so many people. I'm obsessed with like 25
people right now. Okay.
It's exhausting. I have to spend all day and night being obsessed
with these >> See though, >> it's kind of negative
against it. It's >> I mean, and so that's what you guys
that's what you guys choose to see about about my platform, but
I like to break out a lot of data data visualizations. Like that's
my main right there. So, I mean that's cool. You guys can say
what you want about me, but >> don't [__] get
people to [__] >> What does data visualization
have to have a book? >> Well, I mean just like my the political
work I like to do. That's all I was talking about. Whoever's
in the >> that's cool. I I bet you >> Oh, yeah. And
like I you know, I'm not telling you guys you guys can't do something.
That's helpful. Like I think that like you know what's going
on, Kyler. I've heard you speak a little bit. Like it's cool.
Um I'm I'm just like the actual foundation of what's going on
is really strange and I'm sorry the money looks sketchy. Like
if you actually look at it, I've never seen something like this.
Alison, that's I'm what I'm saying to you. So my whole position
that you I guess would have had to retreat. That's fair. You're
totally
>> Okay. Why are you talking? >> So it seems like
Allison's not actually making allegations of fraud. She is she's
just explaining I find this sketchy as somebody with experience
in this field. I find this sketchy.
I don't know what what more do you want her to do. Oh,
four minutes. Okay.
Or we'll we'll watch this later. >> [__] speak
video. I'm not talking to you like she's just really nice. >> Yeah,
I know. This is just really weird. I'm like I don't I feel like
I'm being like a [__] [__] It's totally
>> Oh, it was Arite who started Okay, hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. >> Not talking to you like that. My whole position
that you I guess would have to That's fair. You're totally valid.
>> Okay. Why are you talking to me like I'm a child? What
the >> I'm not talking to you like that. >> She is
totally okay. That was one of the things that we weren't sure
about. She is totally talking to her like she's a child, right?
Or a horse, actually. It's okay. I am not talking to you like
a child at all.
>> Yeah, I know. This is just really weird. I'm like, I
don't I feel like I'm being like, what's going on? >> Stop
being a >> Yeah, I know. This is Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. >> Really weird. I'm like I don't I feel like
I'm being >> Oh, Eric actually says this later is I asked
her if she if she wanted me to be mean and she said yes. Did
she say no? >> Stop being a It's
fair. You're totally >> val.
Yeah, I know. This is just really weird. I'm like I don't I feel
like I'm being what's going on.
>> I don't know what's going on.
>> Airite represents this later is I asked you if you didn't
think I was engaging fairly or or kindly. Did you want me to
be more mean? And you said yes.
And you said yes. So I was more mean. But actually she's like,
"Oh, you want me to be more mean? Well, you're >> no. It's
totally fine. to the IRS. If you're actually concerned about
these, you want me to go back to speaking, which
Oh, yo. Okay, listen. And that's where I'm like, y'all just said
that on >> Do you want me Do you want me to be good >> I
mean, that was that was not good
>> define good faith. Define good faith.
>> Everybody is bad at consent. You don't
>> We understand the history behind it. Like, seriously.
Also, >> this is a
>> legendary moment. Okay,
>> I believe it's at is it at this point where this stream
gets banned from the platform?
Is this the one that gets banned or cuz one of these people gets
banned
because of this, right? Is actually against the Tik Tok toos
and you apparently they got banned for this. >> You were
trying to be good faith this whole time, but like you got mad
that she was being good faith and that's what >> was not
good faith honey. I I could
>> the whole entire time she was trying to be good faith.
So there's two options. I can keep talking to you. >> It's
cuz I asked you to stop talking to me like a child cuz you had
to say our word five times. What is is mother Mary going to pop
out soon?
The whole entire time. >> So I said I said that there were
>> I I know that you think you're doing well cuz of the
chat like >> Oh, is she going to do the lie right here
too? >> Super supportive of you in any other social space.
I was talking to you calmly. I don't know you super well. So,
I'm talking in like a >> She didn't say you were being
like loud or yelling at her. She said you were treating me like
a child, which you were. You were talking down to her. You were
doing the calm like you're a complete but I'll explain it to
you cuz I'm exhaust I'm exhausted, but I'll explain it to you.
You're doing that
>> Yeah. Mercedes, are you okay with that slur? Are you
going to say it to I'm just asking?
>> I've talked to you for a couple hours on the phone,
so I want to know cuz I I've tal I feel like I know you a little
bit better than what you're doing right now. >> Uh-oh.
Swinging out over the slurs. Aite was about to bury herself.
Yeah, but >> these lefty Tik Tockers, they're they're like
good. They're like exposing some uh hypocrisy, some weird. Okay,
but then they just take it too far and they like then they have
to soy about slurs or about misogyny. Just let this person hang
themselves. Okay, just let them do >> So then the right
so we but the thing is about like the left is like we exist in
a space where we can disagree with each other and not like tear
each other apart. And that's the thing is like Kyla is trying
to debate in good faith, but then you got mad that she was debating
in good faith. >> All I'm trying to explain is that Ziko
and Sanchez has directed 30 $300,000 back to Soul Strategies.
Is that
>> where was she debating in good faith? Allison has a
point. You're explicitly not engaging with that point and you're
trying to shame her for asking that question. Now, I'd have to
see some of her other content cuz maybe maybe they have reason
to think she's unhinged. Maybe maybe she's actually talking about
like maybe if I go to her like uh maybe if I go to her Tik Tok
page, it's actually her doing like a genealogy of Z Coen Sanchez
to show that she's tied to like the uh whatever the guy's name
is who got the first case with the ADL. Okay, the ADL was formed
to defend. Maybe it's like actually anti-semitic. Okay, maybe
it's actually just they're straight up doing like uh like early
life rating from Wikipedia or something. I don't know. Maybe
that's what it is. And then it would be maybe you don't want
to engage with this person in good faith. I don't think so. I
I don't think so based on the
her sowing out over right now. >> Is a company that she
owns without and that's why
>> that's about where they get clapped off the platform.
All right. Leo Frank, that's the one. All right. Allison didn't
even get to make her point cuz NYSE just kept cutting her off.
Yep. See, there's a new Hassan content cop. But it's the first
five minutes and is actually not on